I'll be talking a bit today about how
what type of problems were interested in
Shutterstock and how deep learning has
affected the way we approach them we've
been in business 15 years we work around
the world we help people find better
imagery for their websites their
advertising worked with a lot of third
parties doing that but also directly
like recently I looked at a map that we
showed download activity for the last
less than a week around the world you
couldn't find a country on there we
weren't getting downloads from other
than like all of Africa there was one
country southern Sudan they probably
have no internet the Falkland Islands
Greenland there was downloads across the
board so we support a lot of languages
and there's different tastes and to what
people actually like so what type of
problems do we deal with we're dealing
with helping people find the right
images at the right moment we have an
architecture to handle that I'll talk a
bit about that briefly then really get
into why data science matters and how we
use it a bit briefly and then get into
examples of products you can discuss for
different products that we have in these
areas that use deep learning and how we
use it and what type of results we get
the basic problem we're dealing with an
image search and there's some thumbnails
is a typical screen when person types of
keyword we show them a hundred images
and that's quite a few to pick from then
they tell us to throw that further
keyword searching or they pick an image
and they click on it and say I want more
like that similar images we have to come
up with the right combination of images
for the mass electrum some users are
very focused they know they're doing an
ad for a group am for an agency they're
doing some sort of Chrysler ad maybe
other people not sure what they want
maybe they're creating a new website not
sure what themes to use very broad
audiences we sell many things we sell
imagery we sell video footage we saw
music actually have original music and
we have contributor all these things are
firm contributors mostly
majority and we sell editorial tools
services to make all these things better
we help people both small single
individual users SM B's and large
corporations everything in between
around the world word is deep learning
plug into this it plugs into quite a few
places actually and you know the first
place that you see it is this works
that doesn't matter ingestion so we get
contributors upload imagery they try to
make some guesses as to what keywords to
put with a crowdsourcing type page we
give them some help we then review it
possibly and it enters the system
certainly that's an area where deep
learning could help out a lot detecting
what are the right tags complementing
their tag choices reviewing the the
content that comes in grouping it but
the real area we spend most of our time
is discovery and exploring discovery we
really look at is you're not sure what
you want you're just searching around
for things and exploring this more
you're on a focused path either way you
want to find solutions that make sense
and so that those are two main areas
both ingestion review and then of course
discovery exploring or where we help out
people a lot
the problem is here's example of a tag
set we get on one of our imagery this is
real I checked it even before this
briefing you just type that SKU number
the ID number in the hour window for the
search item and will come right up and
you see in red some very interesting
terms you could debate whether you agree
that they're all horrible vehicle you
might argue semi correct my favorite
word if there is white I think that's an
excellent choice and so always the test
that you try to give it is if you type
that word in this image appeared would
you want it I think you can see here
these are all one word keyword so I'm
pretty sure I'm correct on that
yuuna grams they're very vague for the
most part they're not great choices
other problems you have with words key
words is that they don't necessarily
mean one thing Jaguar can mean an animal
in South America I can also mean a car
now made in India I believe or owned by
an Indian company we have lots of
traffic on our site
we're number one on our space 51 percent
of people that search on stock image or
something like that
come to our site first this also means
there's a lot of work to be done
typical image archives we have hundreds
and millions of images whether it's
Flickr whether it's us whether it's
somebody else typical image collections
that are being used by people for these
purposes might see 20% to approaching
30% ever get used the rest never gets
seen Flickr recently a few years ago did
a study where they said the ones that
never get seen are they any different
than the ones that are seen their
conclusion was no they're just lucky
that's pretty bad statement when you
think about a lot of potential er what
is happening as far as what's
opportunity here well one is that we
have a lot more data than ever
exponentially growing the last two years
there's more dent data generated than
the previous all of time and its
continuing accelerating also we have
Moore's Law we have more computational
power than ever I remember even 1314
years ago people were saying that well
CPUs are capped out I can only do so
many cores and then Nvidia came on as
the graph shows here another thing that
happened certainly is
the birth of Alec's net geoff hinton
students alex and alia particularly alex
i guess that's what they named it alex
net i guess we're doing a classification
competition trying to classify from a
large million point four I'd leave
images something like that trying to
classify into one thousand categories
they're convolutional neural networks
based their architecture shown here the
the competition by more than 10% my
closer to 15% so the people before the
competition we're getting like 72
percent accuracy they received something
like 85 that is a singularity moment in
the industry before this point people I
remember even though in the early 90s
were singing the praises of AI neural
networks came along people hated them
they became taboo to even use the word
because he couldn't explain what was
going on inside of him now with this you
see results that are unreplicated well
with any other technology you've seen
industries computer vision natural
language processing now we're all
dominated by deep learning all previous
machine learning techniques are not used
by any of the major players what type of
platform do we work upon well it's
typically AWS platform last time I'll
ring their Bell but they're really good
what they do we use docker we use
kubernetes so we have micro service
architecture mainly API type services
we're offering across literally
thousands of pods huge numbers of
services we collect data for Asia Slee
with Kafka large data lakes we persist
it in all sorts of forms as three
buckets cassandra hive spark even SQL of
course we have data science going on we
use data bricks to connect to spark
clusters and things like that we use a
Jupiter I'd love to but I think Jupiter
is amazing we're trying to use it more
and more Garcias Python we use other
things we use R we use Mathematica even
when it makes sense we're really big on
github and we have continuous deployment
so if you check something in a github a
PR and it's approved it can then
percolate automatically right out
through dev QA to prod with proper
testing what frameworks to be used for
deep learning we use tensor flow we like
chaos we use cafe we use pipe torch
here's an example of network here Google
a net
but there's so many we're not bound to
one but TF is our favorite certainly we
like to use that the most it's the one
that's most widely adopted clearly the
best support as we're doing our science
before we get into actual solutions we
have to be able to tell whether it's
better or worse than previous results a
be testing for lack of a better word
this is one fairly recent test we did
I'm sorry the two graphs they're so
similar in color but the lighter color
lighter orange is the control group that
means it's the old algorithm red
variation is the new one this is showing
click-through rates as they function a
position on page position on page x-axis
click-through rate y-axis hide
dependency and position on page what you
see is the two are not different no
benefit so short answer the new
algorithm didn't make it negative result
this is a quick example of languages we
support up to 21 languages this is
comparing x-axis as the language in a
dictionary of recommended key words the
y-axis is looking at what actual
language is there we're using machine
learning and so forth to identify which
language is actually present and
sampling all these key words you can see
only a few languages do well English is
all English Russian is all Russian but
many other languages including Dutch is
mostly English and same with many other
Portuguese so forth so you would expect
a good result they're all in the
diagonal this case they're not they got
further work to do
part of knowing where you're at so you
can improve it lastly a lot of key words
and things depend upon time so if you're
comparing result from 3 months ago to
result now what do you comparing if the
results vary a lot by time this case the
word pool swimming pool of course this
is North America and not Australia where
it's six months difference you have to
know how to handle that and normalize
your data correctly
what type of products do we work on this
is one safe search so it's becoming an
important topic which is maybe you don't
want to show guns maybe don't show
violence and your results maybe you
don't want to show nudity maybe you
don't want to show marijuana for some
reason maybe I don't want to show drugs
yet to define what that is traditionally
what's been done in these cases is you
use tags contributed by contributors
like we do the problems are not very
accurate if you look at things like Mary
Jane here you might get thirty forty
percent accuracy if you're lucky
looking at tags might if you create a
binary classifier trained image looking
at the actual images do it correctly you
can get human acker seeing get 95%
accuracy you know what you're doing you
can also tweak it for your definition of
what it is clearly nudity in California
it's not the same definition nudity and
Dubai so depending upon where you are
you create like a spec and say this is
what it is is what it's not when you
train it correctly but then after that
it's all computer I'll beep learning
taking care of it the main area we spend
a lot of time on though is here you type
a keyword here Mount Baker then you have
a scheme in the northwest might heard of
this place particularly snowboarders a
couple pictures of it there particularly
the one I'm pointing at right now you
can't see it right there yeah so this is
based on keywords so you type the
keyword this says looking through the
tags that this is what we see that are
the best choices most popular choices
now let's say I really like number two
in the first row and I want to see more
of the same so you click on right here
similar image and you go to this well
all these images are done with deep
learning these are a computer algorithm
it's taking each of these images it's
created an image vector fixed-length
it then compares them and it decides
which ones are closest and that's what
you're seeing here now obviously there's
lots of ways you could do that
you could do that where you want very
similar imagery you want identical
pictures other cases you might want to
take into account the people bought or
downloaded the image that they like when
they also downloaded other images at the
same search many ways you can look at it
but this is a very different result this
is not tags at all this is all deep
learning a lot of the algorithms we use
are based upon that core principle
similar image search we can then take
that algorithm and build upon it let's
say that we want to calculate tags for a
new image in a different way different
than I showed you a minute ago different
than the tags that are on our site right
now we could take a given image and we
could say what images are similar like
we just did a minute ago then we could
look at what keywords they showed up on
those images and how they performed on
those pages that gives you a real idea
about performance as to how well they
performed in actual user situations
consumer situations the problem that you
have is that you're not sure how to
normalize the data because we showed
earlier blue curve below that your
click-through rate depends upon where
you're at on the page where your display
we can normalize the data as we're doing
here and produce the univers probability
of click-through type number that the
orange graph then allows you to compare
position one with position 23 with
position 44 results and they're all
comparable now you make correct
decisions if you do that you can get
results like this notice that these
results are not unit grams they're
almost no unit grams they're more like
what humans type and think they're not
perfect any of these results can be
imperfect but they're a lot more perfect
than we saw a minute ago look at the one
here in the middle jumping child
isolated ice kids isolated on why little
child dancing so forth this one here a
cool girl art one
with backpack disco dress I'm not sure
that's perfect
these are all keywords were people when
they saw that image being displayed with
that keyword they clicked on it it's
actually has crossed millions and
millions of search events across
millions of images I mean you actually
look at the results you see something
like this now instead of all you know
grams you have by grams two keyword
phrases trigrams even four keyword
phrases ahead of one keyword phrase the
first column column one so we think this
is a much better solution now imagine
that you want to do something more
complicated you want to find imagery
where you want to know you want to type
keywords want them to be related to the
image you want them to possess those
objects and you want to tell it where to
put their objects in the screen
positional spatial dependence
that's a tough problem example here we
tell it and this is a live site and go
that link and play with it for free no
cost here we tell it wine on the left
cheese on the right you look at the
imagery it's pretty good you can also
find cases where it screws up but pretty
impressive you're looking at hundreds of
millions of images you can clearly get
wrong results not impossible but it's
able to do things that very quickly and
this is all done in fractions of a
second not hours nothing like that okay
you can tell it other things you can say
oh I want to have a house behind
upper-left car bottom right does a
pretty good job now some of these things
aren't houses this lady and the bottom
was that she's in an airport this might
be in a car dealership showroom but you
get the idea so how do you do this what
technology is to use it's clearly not
just a binary classifier it's clearly
not similar image but it's built on some
of those technologies well we use all
the following in general terms
so we're using convolutional neural nets
we're using and I'm gonna show how we
use these a bit for both vision and
natural language processing keywords
we're looking at where on the image do I
care about what's there how do I
determine that without being told ahead
of time where it is how do i embed this
information to bring it all together for
one solution how do I actually solve for
the best solution that's dimensionality
reduction in and then of course inverted
multi index so it's it's a tough problem
it can't be understated how hard it is
when you look at simply look at just the
keyword phrase you know you type
something like pretty art or whatever
read abstract art which you know what
that picture is no you don't so there's
a huge mismatch between what the
keywords say and what the image shows
they're not close to each other
luckily we have a lot of images and so
we can learn through example and we can
make up for mistakes with volume and
therefore we can handle issues that
potentially are insurmountable any small
sample the first fundamental part we
look at is of course you have one image
and you have group images you already
know the answer to you calculate each as
a cross through a CNN inference mode
that you already trained and on many
millions of images first one of these we
created a few years ago took a month to
generate now you can do it quicker
aw else keeps getting better it's clear
it's it's a significant amount of work
but once you have it learn what it needs
to know now when you use it
inference mode you say tell me about
this image it's quick fraction of a
second so you say what is the image
vector for the bike what is the image
vector for my whole collection now let's
compare the two and you're interested in
knowing which ones compare the best
which ones do I think are likely to be
the best solutions
clearly as you add now keywords to it
now you're dealing with multimodal
embedding so you have embedding you
create a vector relating the keyword to
the imagery you have vectors for the
images themselves and then you bring
them together to tell you which are the
closest in both spaces referencing this
work here we're basically doing is we
train the vision model first we train
the language model second and then we
look at what is the best approach for
that a MIPS type calculation so we're
looking at how which ones are closest to
each other if you look at what these
results actually look like here's an
example I think I can run in here my one
dangerous video to run so here you have
cats and see it makes some sense nice
which is something like bike and you see
a very different looking result so these
are doing no spatial yet but they're
doing keywords and imagery together at
this point we don't know where the
stuff's located we just want this stuff
it looks reasonable you do something
much longer you give it a lemur now I
couldn't tell you for sure what a lemur
was I think they have a ringtail like a
raccoon so I think some of these are
correct and I'm not a biologist they're
all correct even better I don't know I'm
a lemur expert Madagascar s few times I
think it's pretty good movie actually
this one's interesting to give it all
five things so you're basically saying a
family on the beach at sunset and you
see those type of pictures still you're
not saying where the Sun is where the
people are you're not specifying that
yet but you're doing a pretty good job
may take away the at sunset part you see
different set of pictures so you can see
that it does understand with multimodal
embedding as to there's these things in
the image but doesn't know where they
are and then it tries to match the best
ones and we do various other aspects to
try to get that but it's doing a pretty
fine job and this is of course a
business meeting type
so at this point now it becomes a
challenges we're in the picture is the
stuff we care about and so this is a
third pillar that we're working on or we
create feature Maps we're pooling the
information we're doing global average
pooling and we're coming up with the
best solution here's an example of one
you can see this case identified mouths
identified chainsaws and people's faces
there's references to it you can look at
the actual math of it it's not simple
but it's doable it's not crazy or we're
coming up with here this is a way to get
around having the idea with you know
pixel level knowledge able to infer it
through other information now you can
see a lemur where it did a pretty good
job or murk at Mercado gonna wrong
different movie I think that's another
one maybe are they the same thing look
like you could be right Helena here's a
bike mountain bike type episode now we
found there's some other ways to cast
this your salience see casting we found
this to be a bit better we're still
playing with it everything I'm showing
you here is rather deep research stuff
this point still though we let people
play with that on our site you can see
you can see where the people are now you
bring all three together so now you're
looking at you determine things that you
care about you apply the vision model
you a pilot language model you bring it
all together and you get the best images
not something simple to do things we
noticed and things we learned like any
deep learning exercise this is not easy
a lot of trial and error mainly errors
sort of Thomas Edison stuff we'd use the
variant of Inception v3 model but we're
not using batch normalization we found
it had issues we also are using a lose
exponential linear units for a
non-linearity that we introduced instead
of a lose there's references to that
we're also as far as language model goes
we're not using LST M
because they cause massive overfitting
in these cases we are using a different
approach words with no recurrency of
convolutional neural networks we're
getting good results so it's like so
many things you do in deep learning you
have to try various techniques some
works summed up sometimes you know why
sometimes you don't know why and you
have to just try until you find the ones
that work best the basic optimization
that we're doing is we're looking at the
anchor weights and we're looking at
weights between them and the imagery and
the keywords socio those images or
calculating the best optimization and
normalizing it something like this those
is grossly simplified but we are trying
to find little Calla T where we think
they are located within the image the
things we care about the wine glass the
car still when we get down to the end we
have a pretty hard problem if you look
at a typical inverted index type
calculation that you have to do at the
end it's pretty hideous so if you do an
inverted multi index as referenced here
becomes more of a Cartesian type problem
something much more solvable other
things that I'm leaving out but we're
happy to discuss but it's part of what
we do is that even though the things
that I portrayed here of a certain form
that last formula that I showed you it's
still so large the space that you're
searching that you have a very hard time
so you have to do further
simplifications to get it to something
even with all of our great computational
power so we have to do this fairly
quickly where do these solutions lie on
the spectrum of possible solutions
well they they're not fully supervised
we have tags telling us what's in the
image we don't have tags telling us
where it's in the image if you look at
the most extreme case and there's many
examples this people actually use like
gaming engines and they'll create
imagery within the gaming engine where
they know down to the pixel where that
human is sitting where that
our is sitting where that fire hydrant
is City that's very different than what
we're doing here
of course we like to get to is more
unsupervised type use that's for their
research some people predict that's the
future probably is there's far more
unsupervised you know unlabeled data out
there the nurse labeled data about the
end of the day when you get through with
this results I encourage you to go play
with it it's pretty fun they look pretty
good and this is an example of helping
people find the right image doesn't mean
everything is perfect you have to try it
out see what you think
as far as what we're going to be doing
next we're really focused on
particularly AR and VR particularly our
first augmented reality so adding things
to imagery that may or may not be
they're really not there changing there
was a good article recently a Microsoft
did or they made people smile better
using again technology I think you're
gonna see a lot of that in imagery so be
a lot more than just making your eyes
not read it's gonna be changing a lot of
things about the image that you're
looking at he wanted to stand in front
of a blue screen it's remember that most
images now affect all the things in our
archives are taken with camera
very few are modified pretty much none
in a very short time you're gonna see in
next few years a huge percentage will be
modified and you won't they'll tell them
from the other ones they'll pass the
Turing test that Turing test
we call them synthetic imagery and then
ugh all the way to VR where they
compress images that aren't even from a
camera at all they're totally synthetic
and we see a lot of opportunity there
and I think all this relies upon deep
learning I appreciate your time today
thank you
[Applause]
right now we don't you know the
contributors contributing you'll see a
lot of cases where contributors do a lot
of the same shot slightly varied or not
varied at all we try to detect which
ones are the same and remove them on
ingestion but we might fail that is an
area of concern and just like we need to
show similar images or in a person
searches they don't want to see the same
picture of the dog and boy a hundred
times they want to see other dogs and
other children or other things so
particularly you go to similar image you
really want it to branch out but a
normal similar image deep learning
algorithm just wants to find exact
matches most of the benchmark advocating
academic type benchmark so that way
they're saying find the same picture
again and again again we don't want that
we want other things folded in there
like click-through downloads how they
interact with the media how it did
overall so there's a lot more
information we can fold in there we can
embed to do a better job and takes a lot
of experimentation so we're always one
thing that didn't mention is that you
know all of our testing 90 plus percent
of it is done in production we can do
rack testing in dev and QA but it
doesn't tell us hardly anything and you
go to production so you split stream
tested you put 5% your traffic on that
new thing and then you see what really
works and until you do that you really
don't know is there such a wide variety
of things that can happen so the
importance of you know real-time testing
or production testing
I call it track testing like racecars
you don't know until you know you going
oh so much and so we really put a lot of
emphasis on learning in production so as
you go to production we instrument
everything we're looking at did it match
what we expect and then when you see new
things is that because there's a bug
something you can't explain or isn't an
opportunity it's a phenomenon that you
can do better at or you can take
advantage of any other questions yes
yep
v3 modified it yeah there's tons of
architectures maybe in debate within our
own team I mean I think the really
result is put in in production and judge
accordingly and it's like art and we're
dealing with art right imagery you could
argue that which picture is prettiest I
don't know which one you like so I think
that's also why that track testing is so
important which is on aggregate how do
you do those like Moneyball right you
might have stats that aren't that great
but as a team you're a better team than
an individual and so we really have to
look at you know how we like with
similar images when we show you a
hundred images how an aggregate do we
perform and as we do tweaks like one of
the hardest problems there's been some
really good articles written by YouTube
and we have a lot of work in this area
which is as you get new imagery how do
you get it on that front page it's a
cold start problem people refer to it as
it's a bugger because you don't want to
waste real estate right you don't want
to lose money but you have to test new
images give them a chance and so it's
it's a constant research area but I
think that's a great question and
trade-offs yes
we definitely use transfer learning only
a fool would not we definitely do some
hyper parameter tuning absolutely we do
a lot of custom datasets we tagged
ourselves it's all the buzz on the table
it's really about the results right it's
really about what are the results and
getting there in a timely manner which
is really the key part you can't be
satisfied with just making a production
you have to see how you do in production
and learn I think the best practitioner
of that has been Google search nearly
release more than 600 changes a year
that's like two a day they don't know
what those are gonna do really
if the monitor and prod has they
demonstrated a whole bunch of times over
the last what ever since 1998 so and
since they start doing ads whatever in
like 2004 or something so it's it's very
challenging but it's that's why you be
prod testing other questions yes
absolutely it's when the initiatives our
CEO is really pushing right now just the
whole issue of countries you know if I'm
in Singapore and I asked for coffee
shops do I really want to see pictures
from Seattle
probably not but that means you have to
be able to handle that binary classifier
issue that I showed earlier can you
identify or can you trust your tags
then you tell you right now you cannot
the tags are not reliable they are bad
so in general you have to figure out
ways to do it with deep learning but I
think it's really a great experiment
that's just starting now which is that
issue and we don't have answers yet yes
we don't use that but it's a good point
but we don't use Google Maps or any of
that but the users do tell us and a lot
of imagery does come with lat/long type
information attached to it so there's
things you one can do and I can't speak
a lot further than that yeah but it's
it's a hard hard problem that you bring
up and it's you can't look at old
results and say well they're clearly
better when you haven't tried the new
approach right you try something truly
new if you try and jected do injections
where we'll have a certain percentage of
those hundred results or something
totally different different algorithm
maybe they're brand new images in that
topic maybe a competing topical area
there's also semantic search issues you
could use to help with this so it's it's
a good research area it's not going to
go away yes yes
I wish I could claim we're perfect at
that we're not that's a goal yes we do
sample frames and we do apply these type
technologies and but everybody's having
problems to that including Netflix
everyone he does footage YouTube has
problems with that because one or eight
unique example every second typical rep
rates you're looking at even at 30
frames a second that's 1,800 frames per
minute pictures you have to look at that
videos 10 minutes long that's 18,000
that's only a 30 you go to 60 it's
double 36,000 it quickly becomes an
untenable problem I think there's not
many great examples of that currently
doing super well and then there's also
the issue of music how do you sample
music how do you know what's there how
do you know what is a reasonable sample
window to look at we determined on our
music which instruments are present and
we record that we do that with DL ml
type technologies so it's good question
it's certainly a hot area it's a growth
area for us we see it coming up it's
being more and more important other
questions yes
well as far as for a similar image as
for yeah similar image they typically
around 2048 those type of numbers
it varies that's a debate topic too we
tested all different sizes factors of 2
3 4 up and down around that you lose
fidelity as you go much small you go to
512 you lose quite a bit as you go
higher it gets diminishing returns so
usually it's 2048 type numbers are
playing with yeah it depends which one
you're embedding you know it's what type
of embeddings are you using so we didn't
leave the pure image vector like a
mermaid director service or whether
you're dealing with and bending the
keyword information into the vector and
so forth and music is different and so
yeah it's a continuing research area and
there's lots of debate about which ones
are best it's all about testing and prod
I mean that the reality is when the
attitudes we have is that I leave this
group is that we must be able to test it
in prod it's one of the things we figure
out before we do the research how might
we test we don't have all the answers we
have to some idea and some credible
belief that we can actually test it in
prod so you create something and then
you can't test it in prod it becomes
there makes it to production it doesn't
stay there that's for sure
other questions yes we use a lot of s3
and we use other technologies Cassandra
and things for storing information about
them we use Akamai a lot give them a
touching we like Akamai use it quite a
bit makes sense you know it's about
minimizing the time to get it to you
other questions yes
hence mount we're doing like that
language confusion matrix I showed up
here that was a WS the truth
source of truth the y-axis was that for
most other things like image recognition
stuff we do better so it's no real point
also the scale we're doing it just isn't
financially viable now I'll so even like
with binary classifiers we have to know
more than just accuracy we have to know
precision recall other information they
don't provide on the model so we can't
use it and also we have to be able to
hand to numb you some one client make up
a company Facebook they want a certain
thing another client
IBM may want a very different thing how
they define nudity for the case they're
dealing with drugs whatever and then one
of the one of my favorite ones recently
as they asked us to ban Taliban and I'm
like what's that it to define it right
so it's tricky yeah just a person in a
uniform doesn't make them a terrorist
and the back most I was in the military
for ten years the US Air Force and no
they're not terrorists by in general
people and we have lots of military
pictures yes yep we have a very active
work in that area right now extremely
active it's it's a growth area for us we
feel other questions yes
yes
obsolete may not be the right term but I
think they'll become OB competition
there'll be significant competition and
I'm not sure I'll that it'll turn out
you can already see examples right now
where people use you know style
transfers and see one of my picture in
LinkedIn where I did a van Gogh it you
know like deep art calm stuff you're
going to see a lot more of that and
there's been some good examples with
that have shown that they can do some
pretty interesting things but talk
particularly like when they look at they
call it deep dreams or something where
they're looking at the learnings that
the network is acquired and how it
envisions things there's opportunities
here so whether that's gonna make
photography go away I hope not because
we allow photographers we work with them
around the world seventy percent of our
contributors are not from North America
they use it from all over other places
other questions yes Lester
yeah oh it's no problem yeah we chose to
that case not to use it because when it
was used it comes from yeah I can't
speak a lot more about it yep
well that's always the debate right it's
that the choices you make and hyper
parameter tuning and architecture these
dropout rate what dropout rate to use
batch normalization there's a great talk
I believe of nips in the last year where
the guy made fun of it at length for a
long time Mickey went viral
I think batch normalization usually
makes sense usually but you can see
cases where it doesn't and so it's case
by case and you have to have some
experience with what is a good answer we
have other models that we trust and so
we're comparing and contrasting that's
one of the ways we do sanity check
source of truth because the reality is
we can't look at all the weights and
biases and the architecture and judge
you know we can't do that it's really
not viable
I mentioned in that one reference I
think this will be available but we're
using a word recurrence e non recurrence
e-excuse me and we're using a CNN
convolutional neural network for the
that part for the keyword part and it's
there's a paper reference in there and
stuff too we like to share that and I
appreciate your time any more questions
you can see me over here thank you
[Applause]